over the weekend the GLAAD Media Awards
honored Madonna who accepted the
advocate for change award celebrating
the work she's done and continues to do
for the LGBTQ community it means
something to me because I put a lot of
blood sweat and tears into all the work
that I've done over the years advocating
for change so with the recent honor I
thought it would be fun to take a look
at what our in my opinion
calm down Madonna fans Madonna's top 5
LGBTQ anthems at number 5 is express
yourself
[Music]
not only does the song empower us to
never forget to unapologetically express
who we are which is important for those
within the LGBTQ community but Madonna
also played with gender fluid fashion in
the video in at number four is open your
heart
[Music]
now this may seem like a strange choice
but the video actually pays respect to
gay icons including Liza Minnelli
[Music]
and at the 2014 Grammy Awards Queen
Latifah officiated the unions of over 30
couples including gay couples while
Madonna performed the song beautiful in
at number three is Material Girl the
video pays respect to the beautiful
Marilyn Monroe who was a gay icon in her
own right Plus diamonds are a non
gender-specific person's best friend
right
[Music]
just narrowly missing the number-one
position on my list and coming in at
number two is one of my personal
favorite Madonna tracks ever hung up
proving she is the queen of reinvention
the disco-pop Abba sample track had
everyone gagging from the first listens
then watching Madonna dance in a hot
pink leotard in the music video
you got an iconic Madonna moment
[Music]
and number one on my list of the queen
of pops LGBTQ anthems
drumroll beau vogue topped the charts in
over 30 countries and was inspired by
black and Latino ball culture in New
York City the song of video helped bring
queer culture mainstream and it's
currently being explored more with the
incredible series posed and if you
haven't seen the film Paris is burning
watch it tonight the song and video for
VOC remains one of the most iconic of
the singers career
[Music]
do you agree with me
what Madonna songs do you think I missed
would you call Madonna one of the
biggest LGBTQ icons of all time how
excited are you for her upcoming album
madam X let me know in the comments
below and don't forget to subscribe to
ET Canada's YouTube page
you